bonsoir je sais pas quoi penser des prix
s'est pas quoi penser des récompenses
je me rappelle qu'au début de la bible
et à une compétition devant dieu entre
qu'un et abel et ça a mal tourné
là je me demande qu'est-ce qu'on
essayait de nous faire comprendre à ce
qu' il n'y a pas d'un côté les gentils
et de l'autre les méchants est ce qu a
pas d'un côté ceux qui ont raison et de
l'autre côté ceux qui ont peur
est-ce que c'était pour nous faire
comprendre que dans tout jugement il ya
une condamnation et que une condamnation
c'est toujours dangereux mais au fond
moi je pense toujours à une récompense
comme une glace ou gelato quand un jour
de grande chaleur c'est c'est très
agréable mais c'est éphémère
c'est comme la ces comme le bonheur
comme la joie ou le plaisir ou le
pouvoir ou la gloire mais ce soir avec
ce césar je me souviendrai du plaisir et
du bonheur que j'ai eu sur la belle
époque grâce à nicolas à daniel à dénis
à michael et à tous ceux qui étaient là
tous les jours alors merci
[Applaudissements]